um you know i got to get your comment on
the vice president she's overseas
talking about immigration when she
should be here what's your quick
reaction to that
well that's globalism at us worst
america going around the world defending
the borders of every single country but
our own and that's a big part of the
reason that donald trump was elected is
that we want to press
our government to secure our border here
in the united states this administration
hasn't just failed to secure the border
they've purposefully maliciously opened
that border in order to facilitate
illegal entry into our country in record
smashing numbers you know stephen i've
heard it time and time again my sources
tell me this that you briefed the
administration that if they continue
with the actions that they talked about
on the campaign trail that it was going
to be
severe consequences for america that
people just going to be flooding through
did they take heed to any of those
warnings when you guys were doing the
transition
no in fact if you talk to people who
were senior level career officials
they warned the administration of every
potential disastrous deadly consequence
of removing rescinding or terminating
those policies but they did it anyway
because and i can't underscore this
enough they want large-scale illegal
immigration in other words if they
wanted to tomorrow they could reinstate
remain in mexico they could reinstate
our safe thirds with the northern
triangle countries which allow us to
send people back there right away no
delay they could reinstate our asylum
blocks so that people can't commit
asylum fraud they could do everything
that we did to have functionally zero
zero catch and release but they don't
want that because open borders maximum
migration
is the objective
you know stephen
part of the criticism is they said that
you know the trump administration hated
these people that the trump
administration was responsible for the
climate but how can you not see the
climate that these kids are going
through right now i mean it's record
numbers every month they hit a new
record they break the record for the
month before
these kids are having heat strokes um
they're being pumped with birth control
they're being raped i mean it's pretty
they're being dropped like amazon
packages across the border fence
that's what we're dealing with at the
border
this administration is engaged in
criminal conduct you heard bill who's
running these illegal cross border
entries cartels soulless cartels who
rape who murder who maim who abuse who
beat the biden administration willfully
inflicts this on innocent people by the
tens of thousands they willfully engage
in policies that mean children children
will be sexually abused and sexually
trafficked and that will mean criminals
will get into our country as recently
happened in florida where a man was
brutally knifed to death gruesomely
knifed to death by a 24 year old illegal
alien pretending to be 17 to take
advantage of automatic catch and release
under this administration what they are
doing is morally unforgivable and i hope
every person involved in this will be
brought and halt before congress if
republicans take back the majority to
answer for their crimes against humanity
well i hope they do something when they
take control because you know you had
the former administration that put up
stuff and he didn't have full republican
support back then so if they get control
stephen i hope they actually do what
they promised the voters to do
amen life hangs in the balance these
cartels are the most ruthless
organizations in the world and it's
killing our people with drugs and crime
and gangs it's got
and the administration is aiding and
abiding stephen thanks so much